- everyday systematically deny common
sense and and deny the evidence of your
own eyes and ears about what's right in
front of you like how sex defenses work
I think that creates a habit of
interacting with the world in a way that
says what I study is going to be
completely divorced from every aspect of
day to day life and everybody else I
encounter who's not in my field because
if if you allow any crosstalk between
like you've sort of blank slate gender
ideology and the real world
the ideology crumbles so you can you can
only maintain it behind this wall of
insulation and and that's a terrible
position to be in I don't envy the
people who live their lives that way and
it it all grows inside the walled
gardens of academia and outside of that
it's these you know you get internet
groups from people that sort of were
indoctrinated into these ideas in in
college or and it's also I think in some
ways there's a leveling of the playing
field that a lot of these ideologies
present some people where they they go
no you're not a freak you're okay you
know this there was some silly article
on fat acceptance the other day and it
was talking and then they got a pile
which is fine I accept people who drink
except I've accept all kinds of
unhealthy choices but listen don't lie
to me just don't lie about the physical
reality of what you've done to your body
if you reach four hundred pounds
that's not that's not healthy you're
saying it's healthy you're saying it's
okay
no you're just not dead yet if you lost
200 pounds you would feel wonderful that
would be healthier like if you smoked
every day and you like look no cancer
smoking is healthy no no you're just
you're just but your body is dealing
with it your body's processing it it
won't be able to forever that is exactly
what's going on if you're morbidly obese
and for you to pretend any differently
and to just go on about this fat
acceptance
movement and you know the big beautiful
this and that and like no you're obese
you've eaten too much food if you see a
fat guy how come he doesn't get the same
sort of treatment if you see a morbidly
obese man in his underwear no one's
saying he's beautiful
cuz he's disgusting and he's fat and
he's lazy and he's he's addicted to food
we all know it but if it's a woman were
so inclined to like accept just okay let
her go she's fine you're wonderful
you're beautiful you're amazing
like give her her space we treat them as
if they're incapable of recognizing the
absolute reality of their physical being